hey there and welcome to this lesson on
taking shape layers and bringing them
into 3D space two and a half d space
inside of After Effects and making them
more interesting so what am I talking
about I'm talking about creating
something like we see right here this is
called containment and this is something
that
is a piece I did quite a while back and
it's on Pinterest and people absolutely
love this piece and have asked me over
and over again how to create this so I'm
going to show you how to go about
creating something like this it's not
going to be exact replica of this
because I don't believe in showing
lessons where I just show you step by
step here's how you recreate the exact
same thing I want to show you how to
think for yourself and create your own
type of interesting motion design with
shape layers so let's get started we're
here in After Effects I've got a
composition I'm calling it box one
1080 by 1080 so it's just a square
composition 24 frames a second which is
how I like to work a lot of times and
duration of 240 frames because I want
this to be a 10 second piece
click OK there's a box we're going to go
up here to our uh masking tool but
instead of creating a mouse we're just
going to double click and create a shape
layer and there's our shape layer we
don't want any fill here so let's turn
the fill off I just want like a nice
outline here
and let's go ahead and let's just bring
this down in size
maybe something like that so we can see
it
let's make it 900. let's bring the
stroke size
down to maybe three
and let's go ahead and let's add a trim
path here
and for our trim path let's just start
this
maybe about
17 percent
into 17 and let's offset it
a little bit hearing we can't actually
see anything so let's just offset I
wanted to kind of grow from the center
point kind of here at the horizontal
Center so let's go ahead and turn on
title action say so we can kind of see
what's going on here
and if I bring it down
so it's 17 18. let's just bring that
you know right right up in there that'll
work for me let's set a keyframe and
make them both
1717 and let's just make it a two second
animation so two seconds 24 frames a
second is going to be 48 frames
and I'll zoom in here
and we'll just make it grow
to
something like that
and we'll select both keyframes keyframe
assistant easy ease in so that just kind
of slides into it and comes to a nice
stopping point
with that let's go ahead and command D
to duplicate this rectangle
and with the second rectangle let's just
go into our transform here and let's
rotate it
let's do
90.
and maybe let's bring it
down let's actually go into our path
here
and let's make it a little bit smaller
no exact science here maybe
let's go 700. so there we go look pretty
cool and then let's go ahead and turn
off our title auction safe here
so we've got two
shape layers that kind of draw on here
they do draw on and come to a stopping
point so now let's use a repeater
and there's a repeater
and let's just make it two copies
open up transform properties we don't
want to offset the position
but let's go ahead and offset
the rotation
180 degrees
see what that looks like oops
so now we have this kind of interesting
looking
square that if I preview this
looks pretty cool
I'm gonna hit you on my keyboard and I'm
going to select both all four of these
keyframes and open up My Graph editor
and just take this line here I'm in my
speed graph which is typically how I
like to work
not huge on the value graph I've always
been a speed graph kind of guy
I like that
cool let's make it three-dimensional
just click in that box there now it's a
3D layer
and I'm going to duplicate it so now I
just have a simple duplication of that
same layer I'm going to push it back in
Z space let's go back about
let's go back 200
pixels here
and then let's duplicate again hit P for
position we'll go back
400 pixels
and let's duplicate it again and for
this one we will make it
600 pixels
and let's do one more duplicate again
position and this will be
800.
very simple animation
but you're going to see when we start
bringing this into 3D space with cameras
it gets a lot more interesting right so
if I go to actually two views here I'm
looking at my top view here I can switch
this to custom View and you can see
that my layers are in 3D space here
and we're already starting to get you
know just kind of an idea of what's
Happening here it's just simple shape
layers repeating going back in space
creating a box right so let's go ahead
and let's create another box
okay so here we have box two same deal
it's 1080 by 1080. 24 frames a second
240 frames duration so it's 10 seconds
long and I'm going to again
double click and just create a square
here and we'll go back to one view so we
can see a little bit better
and for this guy
if it's 1008 let's just go down I'll go
down to 900 again
something like that
I think that'll work and then we're also
going to select the box and just make
any ellipse and double click and by
double clicking it actually creates the
shape layer full size and in the
composition and because it's a square
composition it's going to create a full
um Perfect Circle
so let's take this one down really small
maybe something like 10 by 10 and I
don't want a stroke for this one turn
off the stroke
but I do want it to be filled with white
and for this guy let's go ahead and add
a
repeater as well
and the repeater we want to do four
copies
and we don't want it to be offset
in position we want it to be offset in
rotation
probably about 90 degrees and we're not
seeing anything happen yet because we
need to actually move the position
so I'm just dragging this guy out
oh something like maybe you know
negative 450
and I'm thinking we need to go positive
450 as well
if I can make that work
and also because we can barely see those
circles let's make them just a little
bit bigger maybe 15. don't want them to
be too big that may be too big but for
now that's going to work
and I want this just to kind of expand
upwards really quickly so let's set a
keyframe here
and we'll actually do a keyframe easy
ease in and then we'll make it maybe 90
percent not too small
and hit in
and it's it's okay looking
uh could be way more interesting though
right so let's just take that speed
graph again let's make sure we're on the
speed graph here
and let's just
pull it all the way over like that
yeah so just kind of pops into place
turn off the Speed graph and to make it
pop even more
just going to
what I did there was command click and
took off the ease of that keyframe the
first one so that works I'm going to hit
shift t for transparency and let's just
make it fade in really quickly so here
we're at 100 but at the very beginning
we're at zero
yeah something like that and then once
it becomes it rests in a place I want to
have another one that maybe pushes back
in space maybe we'll do two of them so
one will push back I want to push
forward
so we'll do is we'll just duplicate this
layer
and for this we're going to hit P for
position
and we'll set a keyframe right here and
let's do a keyframe easy ease
and let's make it over the course of one
second kind of this one will pop forward
and actually would help if we'd make
these 3D 3D layers so there we go so
this one will pop forward let's make it
pop forward 200 pixels
so let's just take a look at how that
and I want this to overlap just a little
bit here I never am a fan of one action
coming to an end and then another one
beginning a little bit of overlap will
really you know help sell movement
and let's go ahead and take this one and
again we'll just make it
hold that speed graph out
yeah that's nice works for me so I'm
going to duplicate that layer
and instead of going forward negative
200 pixels I'm going to go positive 200
pixels so this one will fly back
so there we go it's looking pretty good
I think that's gonna work for me for
this box so we'll go ahead and save this
one and let's create another one okay so
now we've got box three this is again
1080 by 1080 24 frames a second 240
frames long keeping things very very
simple here very uh you know
I get I guess I preach Simplicity is
always better with Motion Graphics
motion design people get caught up a lot
of times and things being overly
complicated keep it simple limit
yourself and you're going to make
something much more interesting
so again we're at 240 frames but let's
go ahead and zoom in
somewhere in here maybe we'll make
things in about two seconds again
let's go ahead and make another let's do
another rectangle double click there and
this is filled which is great let's make
it so we're going to add a repeater
just like we did with the circles and
there's a repeater and we're not going
to offset the position just like before
we are going to offset uh the rotation
so 90 degrees and then we're going to go
back up into our position here and move
these guys
we'll do the same thing we'll do
negative 450
and we'll do positive 450 and we need to
increase the copies to four
there we go and I'm going to hit shift
command H to turn off my guides here so
I don't see those guides
with guide selected see like I can see
this box here and it kind of drives me
crazy so if I hit shift command H it
turns off the guides
uh let's go ahead and increase the size
into 15 that'll work
and
you know what let's just make this one
by itself it's just it's just gonna be
four corners just like this so we'll go
to 24 frames in
and let's actually make it expand
outwards
so let's do a simple scale
easies and for this guy we actually will
just we'll take it down from
really small so three percent
highlight this guy speed graph
make it just really pop into place yeah
and I am going to take this First
keyframe Command click
yeah I like that looks nice
so this guy kind of fly into place and
actually let's make it happen faster
and change my mind here
that's a little bit too fast let's try
16.
yeah that works
and then we'll do we'll just duplicate
this layer and let's actually just open
up the contents of this layer
and we'll just bring down the size of
let's bring down the size of the
repeater so we'll do the scale
actually that's not going to work
we'll bring down the transform
like that
and I like to be very OCD about this
stuff so we'll go down 20 something like
that we're going to offset this guy so
maybe
columns in we'll go
maybe four frames in and I'm gonna
duplicate this guy
make this one at eight
and this guy we will transform again
down to
make sure I got the right guy here
contents
transform
60.
and let's go one ah
I'm thinking maybe one more time
maybe not
now we're going to take all through
these layers we're gonna make them 3D
layers
works for me and let's just select all
of them let's go right click and let's
pre-compose
and we'll call these
um dots
and for the dots again let's make them
3D here let's duplicate them
and it's working with values of 200
let's just go 200 back
and it's a little bit hard to see here
we can see here what's going on and
let's duplicate again and let's actually
go
negative
200
. now again this looks you know when you
look at this angle here it looks okay if
you look at this angle it looks like
things are overlapping it's not it's not
looking so great
um but when we add some depth of field
here it's going to bring certain things
in focus and certain things out of focus
and it's going to help with that so
we're going to leave this
as is maybe let's add one more
let's just add a real simple
Square
in the middle of this
and let's just bring down
and let's find this guy this is the guy
that's in the center so let's solo this
guy let's solo this guy and let's just
kind of get these guys to line up in a
interesting way
you know maybe something like that
or maybe I just do the inside
yeah I think I might do that one
was a 540 there we go
I don't know this one might work it may
not but let's go ahead and move on and
make another comp
okay so for this next composition we're
going to create actually a circle so
we're calling the circle one again it's
1080 by 1080 24 frames a second 240
frames long good to go and let's
actually go in and let's make an ellipse
if I can make that happen there we go
and
let's just shrink this guy down
maybe 900 by 900 that works for me and
it's also with this
I'm gonna try and keep this as as many
uh shape layers inside of one as many
pieces of content inside of the shape
layer as possible is what how I like to
typically work so I have less layers to
animate uh if I have a lot of layers
going on so let's see what else we need
to create let's make an X inside of here
so to make an X
believe we can do that with the star
tool
and we will change this to
is that four points
and I think we leave it star we need to
take the enter
radius all the way down there we go
okay and let's bring the outer radius
down something like
450
and we can also just rotate this
so it's more of an X and we'll go 45.
yeah that works and then let's also
[Music]
create another ellipse here
and this one will be our fill
with no stroke
and we'll go ahead and take the size of
this down to
10 maybe
Maybe 15.
and we're gonna add a repeater just like
we've been doing lots of repeating kinds
of techniques here as you can see we'll
do four copies
and we're gonna not offset the position
but we're gonna offset the rotation
by 90 and then move the position here
and I actually want to offset
I'll make that 45 you want to offset the
rotation by 45 not
90. is that right nope that's not right
uh let's see here I think we need to
transform rotate now
and I get asked a lot why like why am I
messing with the values inside of the
shape layers versus the just the
transform properties things like that
there's all different ways you can you
can work with this stuff
it's a matter of choice
so I find that I like to work with
values inside of the content of the
shape layer first before I mess with
just like transform values for the
entire shape layer so that way I can
really get things kind of fine-tuned and
then come back in and you know start
animating things so like
maybe for this I want the X
to
maybe like blink on let's try that so
we'll go into the X we'll go and
transform properties for the X
we'll do we'll set a keyframe for a hold
keyframe
so we're at zero
go forward a frame 100 percent
maybe two frames zero one frame it's
coming in
back down
maybe something like that and if I set
my out Point here in
zoom into here
and we'll go back to one view here
yeah so then once the X comes in
so right here maybe we'll have the
maybe the circle will start coming on at
this point
just not these points maybe the points
actually do come on at this point so
we'll set a keyframe here for
opacity and we'll just set one for zero
to start so it'll be
zero there and then 100 here
it's basically like they pop on right
there up on and then they pop on and
then we'll have the
the big ellipse which is this guy right
here
this guy maybe he'll like
do like a scale or something
so we'll do a keyframe easy ease
and maybe he kind of scales in a place
there but here
let's say maybe he's at
that point
and also set a keyframe here for toggle
hold keyframe zero percent
and then he'll pop on right here as well
so let's just see what this looks like
I use my speed graph here
for whatever reason it keeps defaulting
to my value graph I don't know why I'd
have some interesting bugginess with my
After Effects the last couple days
especially today seems like every time
on record I have lots of issues huh
and then maybe when this guy goes full
full on this is where I'm gonna hit RF
rotation I'm gonna have everything
do like an interesting turn so maybe
like a
90 degree turn
and select both
easy ease
speed graph
and I want them both just to kind of
whip around let's just see what that
looks like
that's too much
okay so from here I want to actually
start bringing in all these pre-comps
we've made we've made box one two three
and four actually Circle one so three
boxes one Circle and then I've got my
working comp here and I like to call it
working sometimes sometimes I call it
output but this is kind of like a
pre-comp that's going to go into my
output so this comp is going to be 1920
by 1080. it's an HD TV 24 frames per
second 240 frames long
very basic and then here I've got my
audio track and if I preview this
so that's the original audio that I used
and I've marked some places on here that
I want some things to happen right so
that's why I've got all these different
markers here but I may fine tune these a
little bit more just kind of threw them
up here very quickly to see kind of
where some things are going to happen at
but
I know that that's where I want my
camera to kind of do some interesting
moves like we saw in this original
example here you can see pushes in and
kind of rotates up kind of comes down
and then kind of Fades away as it pushes
you know pulls away so that's what I'm
doing here so
let's go ahead and let's bring in
all of our pre-comps here
and we're going to keep the audio at the
top layer here I'm just going to lock
that layer and layers are all here so
let's go ahead and select the collapse
Transformations button here and that's
just going to say hey look at all these
pre-comps here all these pre-comps have
three D layers separate in space that's
how we built them right so by turning on
collapse Transformations here it makes
it brings those a bit those capabilities
of 3D precomps into our main comp here
right so if I go back here to let's just
say custom View
there we go if I turn off class
Transformations you can see here
everything's flat nothing is reacting I
can make these 3D layers and push them
apart again but if I turn on collapse
Transformations everything is separated
in Z space now they're all at a position
of zero on the Z but we can adjust that
and do things with that if we want to
so here are our layers let's go ahead
and add a new camera
and this is going to be a two node
camera that's great preset of 20
millimeters great enabled depth of field
great which we're gonna go ahead and
turn that off for now you will realize
that I'm using a two node camera here a
lot of times I use OneNote cameras as
you've learned throughout proflows I
find it's way more easier to work with a
OneNote camera but for this type of
Animation a two node is where it's at
and I'll show you why
so there is our two node camera and
because there's a Center Point here
point of interest if I just move the
position of my camera around
just not even playing with point of
interest just position only that point
of Interest stays in place there and you
can see here especially over in here
what's going on right you can start to
see this thing is coming alive right
it's starting to look kind of like
containment which is the one that we
referenced on Pinterest so let me undo
that
bring it back to the center here and
we're just going to start by doing a
very simple we want to end up here let's
do a keyframe easy ease we're going to
use easy ease for all these keys
but um we can actually go ahead and
probably go back to one View and we'll
go back to zero here and at zero I want
to kind of be pulled back I just want to
do a real simple
kind of
truck in it's probably not the right
term
I'm going to push in here
and then I'm going to sit here for a
little bit
like so so I'll set another keyframe
here and I want to push in even quicker
at this point now I do not like being
straight on to this so let's actually
I'm just going to delete everything here
because I want to give it a little bit
more of an interesting angle to start
so maybe something like that I'm also
way too tight
so let's pull it back
and I'm just messing with x and z here
oh maybe something like this is where
I'm going to end up there now I'm going
to right click keyframe easy ease I'm
going to back it up
and we're just going to zoom out a
little bit here
and so we're just push in
and we're going to sit there for a
little bit until here
and then at this point we're going to
push in real quick
so we can really kind of see what's
going on here now you can see this this
circle on this x circle is not reacting
to the camera right so I need to go back
in here I probably did not make it 3D
click that
there we go problem solved
so
let's just see how this looks we're push
in
looks great
pushes even more
sure we're going to sit to about this
point here
then we're going to go let's move up
real fast we're just going to go to the
Y position
[Music]
and
something like
maybe something like this
and we're gonna sit there
and then we're going to whip across real
fast down
this is kind of an interesting move here
I really liked it in the original
[Music]
it's kind of just a real quick like whip
pan
maybe something like that
I'm not gonna mess with the Z too much
there maybe even just gonna get like an
interesting angle on this thing
and then from there we just go all the
way back we just kind of just fade
fade back we just keep kind of
pushing back in space and then it kind
of just
disappears
as we're pushing back in Z space it'll
kind of just fade out or something like
that
so if I preview this you can see
everything happens very quickly and
that's because I want to offset some of
these layers here so maybe
at zero there's nothing there
and we kind of push in here and then
maybe
maybe this guy kind of pops on there
this is all just a matter of
experimentation
and then maybe this guy comes in here
that kind of sits there
and then maybe this guy comes on here
the circle I did like
kind of in this area so we're sitting
here with the cameras maybe the circle
does its thing as we're sitting here
maybe something like that
let me just kind of pull away
yeah something like that
now it looks okay and if I preview this
let me go ahead and save that
and if I preview it I mean it looks okay
um I would probably go in and really
just you know fine tune some of the
timing of these different elements
uh like you saw I
so something needs to happen here like
right in here
uh that's not happening and I don't know
what that actually you know what that
could be
so looking at this this initial outer
box here it feels like it's way too much
right it's way too many layers going on
that's too much for the eye to look at
because I'm if I look at this inside
layer here what are what are the layers
here
so this one
is too much okay so maybe what can
happen is maybe just like a few of these
come on and they're kind of sitting
there and then when we're sitting at
this point maybe this is where the rest
of them kind of appear so I'm gonna go
to that point double click
and
this
is where some of these things are going
to maybe expand more
uh maybe something like that I don't
know
maybe maybe not let's just take a look
no that does not work
so we'll just go back here and I'm
actually going to go ahead and turn off
some of these
maybe one more here
maybe two well let's just try one
and then I'm actually going to go ahead
and
make these three dimensional layers just
so I can push this one back in space
here
I don't like how far out it's sitting
uh maybe I'll bring it in a little bit
here
maybe something like that
yeah
maybe actually I'll just increase the
size of it a bit
and this is just a matter of just you
know Personal Taste and kind of playing
around with
objects and and seeing you know how
things work together how they don't
maybe I could rotate it
on the Y
I did some of this in the original
um and then with the rotate I'm actually
going to go back to zero here
and I'm going to turn off
there's one right here that I don't like
I think it's it's one too many
so I'm gonna go up here new comp viewer
go into my box and find out which one
that is
it's not that one it's that one
so a lot of times this is where the time
starts really kind of playing into it
because you're you're experimenting
you're trying to find out what works
what doesn't work I'm gonna go ahead and
scale it back to 100 percent
um and then I'm also going to at this
point go into my camera options because
this is going to make it look a lot more
interesting we're going to turn on depth
of field we're going to crank our
aperture way up maybe 650.
uh we're gonna also change this to
something like hexagon
to make it look a little bit nicer
and then at this point we're going to
just go in and start making uh the focus
point be where we you know where we want
some interest to happen so we're going
to set our Focus distance here
we're going to set our keyframe easy
ease
to kind of see where we're at here
maybe at this point I'll
kind of pull the focus
forward
like so
maybe have it sit there
I like to really just kind of have fun
here and just bring different elements
into Focus
and there's no right or wrong way to do
this
you know maybe it goes way out of focus
here and then maybe it comes back
to something like that and then as it
pulls away I definitely want it to go
out of focus
something like that
and maybe right here maybe it's
that's kind of nice and then I'll
you know I don't know see how that looks
let's go ahead and save that and let's
take a look
so right in here it needs something
needs to happen here like the these
circles and they do like an interesting
rotation and things like that but um I
want it to maybe pull Focus
so maybe it just
kind of loses some Focus for a second
maybe it
goes back and then maybe it comes back
in
something like so
yeah we'll keep it for that you know
we'll keep it like that for now uh in
the original I also had some text and
things in there so you could you know
add some interesting text here
uh things like if I just type I don't
know
containment
and just
make it 3D and
bring down the size of it a lot
maybe 15 percent
and
and maybe it you know pops on here maybe
that's what it does I don't want to do
it with the camera I don't do it with
the text
so let's kind of centered up here
and then we'll push it back just a
little bit here
something like that and save and then
maybe I'll just do an effect
um decoder fade in that's an easy one
and maybe it just kind of
hops in like that
foreign
right here
works for me
so what we're going to do next is we're
going to create a new composition we're
going to call this one output and same
deal 1920 1080 24 frames a second 240
frames and to that one we're going to
put our working comp into it
and we'll drag that guy in there
and with this guy we are going to go
ahead and just
let's do a little bit of chromatic
aberration
um you can do this several different
ways you can use plugins which is what I
prefer to do you could use Channel
something like shift channels you've
seen this done a thousand
times but red is on
duplicate it
red is off
green is full on
duplicate it
green is off and blue is
blue
and then we're going to set these to a
screen mode
now we're back to White we only need
audio for one of these guys and you can
just play around with the scale position
[Music]
maybe it's 101 maybe this one's
99
maybe this one's
slightly off yeah just a little bit
something like that
um you could also like I said I
typically would use a plug-in for this
but just trying to keep it so you know
those of you who don't want plugins you
can follow along uh also we could do
something where we add a new adjustment
layer we'll call this
um
After Effects it's acting crazy uh let's
add some noise and grain let's add a
little bit of grain here I always like
to finish off pieces with some grain and
we'll go
not super intense something like that
let's also add a background and for the
background
um maybe like a bluish black just
slightly
something like that might be too much
that's a little bit too on blue side but
we'll come back to that
also for effects I want to go ahead and
add a color correction and I want to do
a lumetri color
and what I love about lumetri color is
there's some really awesome creative
looks in here uh things you can just
kind of play around with and get some
really different types of looks
yeah I think maybe I'll stick with that
one for now
um I also want to add another adjustment
layer here
and we'll call this
effects two
and for this one I'm actually going to
add some glow now you can add the
built-in After Effects glow you can use
Optical glow you can use deep glow
there's lots of different glows you can
use here I'm just going to go with
my favorite which is sapphire glow
and um just personal preference I've
been using the sapphire plugins for a
long time and it's my go-to for lighting
and glows and things like that
just got some interesting looks to them
like I said you can use any glow plug-in
built into After Effects not built into
it you name it that's kind of an
interesting look right there
I'm going to go into my uh let's see
here
let's go into our brightness and I'm
going to control all I'm going to alt or
option click on brightness and I'm just
going to add a wiggle expression which I
love the wiggle expression
now let's do
eight times a second maybe with a value
of three
and I'm also going to add a flicker
effect to this
I think maybe not
foreign
let's just take a look at how this looks
yeah Flickr might uh kind of interesting
here so again I'm using a Flickr Express
effect from Sapphire
there's lots of different flicker
effects out there again this is just one
that I personally like campfire it's
just got not kind of like that nice
simple
flicker kind of look to it
um what else we got here what else we
want to do
okay so I can you know tweak this all
day long
um I might try a couple more things
yeah just flopping the order of the
effects here
like that a little bit better
um it's a little bit on the pinkish red
side for me I I don't want it too much
I'm going to sharpen it up a little bit
here
so that's nice that's with
that's without so I definitely like to
sharpen
maybe turn down the Vibrance nah
maybe turn down the saturation
yeah it was a little too saturated so
maybe 62. that's nice curves I want to
bring down
some of that red
yeah
now it's way more on the
blue size and bring a little bit green
into it
back up in here
foreign
take that down sharpen
you don't want to overdo the effects I
see a lot of artists that uh
you know tend to overdo the effects
and you got to be careful about that so
let's just take a look
at how this one looks
yeah I think the the glow might be a
little bit too much for me especially
when we get up in here it's really
intense it's an interesting look
um but it's a little bit intense
the um if I was to duplicate this turn
off this glow
and just go in and pick it like a more
subtle
even like the default glow
like I said depending on what plugins
you're using or the built-in
effects inside of After Effects you're
going to have different results and this
is really what's going to kind of just
change the look
uh make it look one way or another so
I'm just going to go back to default
here and I'm probably gonna
crank up
the
amplitude here the frequency not the
amplitude
foreign
and just kind of take a look at what
this is doing
I did like those kind of streaks that
were happening
vertically which we lose those
completely now
so it's really a matter of the kind of
just in the middle there so I'm going to
change this one to a frequency of 10 and
3. go back to that original glow and
then I think I'm just going to turn down
foreign
not that one
go back into my original here and maybe
turn up the threshold just a little bit
so it doesn't affect as much
yeah that's nice
okay so it's actually been an entire day
and I'm cutting back into this project
the reason is is that I like to have
fresh eyes I like to step away from
projects uh when I'm very deep in those
projects and step away
several hours or a day or two days and
then come back with fresh eyes and so I
can have a New Perspective to see if
things are working or not working and
doing that helps me to have better work
okay so this particular piece now I'm
looking at it and there's some things
about it I don't like right now when
you're in the moment and you're focused
on effects and things like that you can
get really caught up in seeing the same
thing over and over again it looks good
to you but like I said you come back
with fresh eyes and it doesn't and this
is a case of that so the first thing
that I see that's not working for me is
the glow which I you know actually said
I liked it
but it's too much right so that's one
thing so I'm going to turn that off for
now I'm going to probably turn this glow
back on I'm going to make sure
that
it's got the same expression so we're
good to go there
um I'm also going to
decrease
the amount of chromatic aberration and I
think that's going to be this one right
here
it's going to make it less 100.5 and
we'll do this 99
0.5
chromatic aberration just needs to be
very subtle you don't need to do a lot
with it something else
that I'm seeing right off the top here
is that these lines are way too thick
compared to what I originally did which
we can see here okay these are really
thin lines and the dots are small and
that's why it's working right these are
very thin thin lines these are too thick
so I want to go in and I want to
take all my shape layers and I'm just
going to take the stroke with down to
one on everything versus three
so let's do that I also want to take
the the dot size of these down so let's
just go into these really quick
and let's just see what size they are
they're 15. so maybe we'll do
we'll do eight
and I do that for all of these
so make all of them eight
and this is well
I'm already liking this better change it
from three to one
we'll go into these dots here
so these are all fills
and what size are these 15 so we'll do
eight
again open this up
eight again and we'll open this one up
and we'll do eight again as well close
that pre-comp
see that was in
aux three so now we're back to Circle
so we'll make this
one as well maybe we'll leave these dots
a little bit bigger I think I'm okay
with that
and then we'll go into these box
pre-comps here and
I think we're good on these guys
something else I'm seeing here and it's
it's more challenging to see this now
I'm just going to turn the effects off
so I mean already looks better I can see
here that things were off with this box
here which I think
is box four I turned box four off yeah
so you can see
uh it's just weird there's it's mostly
on the left side it's not going across
the entire uh box so I'm gonna do a new
comp viewer so I can see my original
here I'm gonna go into box four
change this to one View and we'll
actually go into
a custom view here just to see what's
going on and let's just go every
other one
and just see how that looks
now I'm not seeing a line over here but
I think that's because it's out of focus
so I go back into my original comp here
hit a a and turn off my depth of field
yeah so now you can see it's right there
so that actually works
way better for me these are just very
small changes that go a long ways when
you're finishing off a piece
so that's looking pretty good and
I also want to go in and I want to bump
up the grain
to Wine I'm just not seeing a lot of it
so we'll bump that up to one
that looks pretty good the lumetri color
is bothering me so I'm actually going to
reset this
and let's go and make a few changes here
so let's go into our creative tab here
and
let's see here I think
a little bit of experimentation here and
I think that's the one
I liked and I'm gonna take my Shadows
over here more into the green
and my tens my highlights a little bit
more in the blue here
and let's just see how that looks
and let me just move this
box here let me move it back
the one that we adjusted move it back
maybe something like that
just one more adjustment layer here
and bring up
the
exposure
maybe in there it might be too much
and I'm also going to do another curves
adjustment here and just take out some
of the red
foreign
something like that
and one last thing here
Maybe
I do like the
I just still don't like that
a little bit of red there
something like that
all right let's take a look
yeah so I'm good with that
yeah really interesting look uh looks
you know different than what you see on
social media but uh
I'm not here to show you step by step
exactly how to recreate something I want
you to go out there and create a your
own magical containment piece so you can
see here really simple using 3D shape
layers in 3D space with some effects and
some camera movement can really bring a
piece to life
[Music]
oh
foreign